[Music]
hello dear friends and thank you for
joining us here and I'd like to know one
of our programs that we enjoy the most
because we can connect with you we can
get your questions
and your inquiries and we love to answer
and study the scriptures so we can give
you an answer from the word of God I am
with Pastor s bour and it is a blessing
to have you Pastor with me but we want
to invite you to get in our Fund in
sending your questions to us by email
and you can send them to the address
that is in the your screens it is TV Sam
tv.org you can email to ask the
questions don't forget to also include
where your from uh what location you're
emailing as the question as we would
like to uh get to know where we're
reaching with our program so we want to
now start today and I will ask Pastor
Bor to lead us into prayer so we can
open God's word let's
pray Father in
Heaven what a privilege it is to call
you father amen because we know that uh
you have the best in mind for us and you
have given us your word assure guide in
a world that is so totally
confused we ask that as we uh answer the
questions in this program today that
your holy spirit will be with us through
the ministry of the angels to Enlighten
our minds amen so that we might speak in
harmony with your holy word yes bless
also all of those who are watching the
program that they might be
blessed we look forward to the day when
we get to heaven and we will be able to
ask questions forever
and we will never have all of the
answers because we will always be
studying and researching so bless us in
this program we pray in Jesus name amen
amen
amen uh thank you fastor for that prayer
and I think it's an important point we
will forever be asking questions and
learning so we encourage people to do
the same as we are able to do it today
uh let's the first question comes to us
from Italy from ehi eii um actually
Joshua is his name it says there hello
and good day Pastor Bor and the whole
team at samtv I am Joshua from Italy my
question is what law or loss was spoken
of not to be perfect because it show
weakness and unpr unprofitableness in
keeping according to Hebrews 7
11-19 thank you so Joshua has a question
and and I'm glad that he reads the Bible
he's studying the book of Hebrews and he
finds that in the verses of chapter 7
particularly he has an issue with 7 11-
19 he mentions there that there is
apparently some laws that is not perfect
that has to change what law is he
speaking of there the Apostle Paul in
this
letter well there's different laws that
God gave to the Jewish
Nation um we have some that uh are
unchangeable mhm and others that are
that are you know done away with um the
ones that are unchangeable are of course
are the moral law The Ten Commandments
yeah they apply you know after the cross
and before the cross and you also have
health laws correct which uh are good in
the Old Testament and New Testament as
well because they have to do with the
body and the body doesn't change MH but
then you have civil laws that apply
directly to the Jewish Nation right and
and you have ceremonial laws or
levitical laws we could call them that
uh existed only during the Hebrew
theocracy and so this is speaking about
um the law of the priesthood during the
Jewish theocracy and and I'm sure you
you'll be able to amplify that point yes
and this is important Pastor I I first
think that we should briefly just read a
few verses from those uh from Hebrews 7
just so we can get a little bit of the
cont context of what is Paul speaking of
in the book of Hebrews in regards to
this uh apparent need of change uh
versus he he mentions there the verses
he has issue are verses 11 uh through 19
and I'll read um I I think that is
important for us to read this this
passage and we'll actually answer once
we read this passage so so we can know
what law he's talking about here he says
therefore if Perfection were through the
levitical priesthood and vers verse 11
I'm reading for under if the people
received the law what further need was
there than another priest should arise
according to the order of melkisedek and
not be called according to the order of
Aaron for the priesthood being Chang of
necessity there is also a change of the
law for his of whom these things are
spoken belonging to another tribe from
which no man has off offic officiated in
the altar for it is evident that our
Lord arose from Judah of which tribe
Moses spoke nothing concerning
priesthood and it is yet far more
evident if in the likeness of melkisedek
there arises another priest who has come
not according to the law of fleshly
commandment but according to the power
of an endless life for he testifies you
are a priest forever according to the
order of madc for on the one hand there
is an an annulling of the former
commandment because of its weakness and
unprofitableness for the law made
nothing perfect on the other hand there
is the bringing in of a better hope
through which we draw near to God so as
we read through this passage it is very
clear that this is not dealing with the
Ten Commandments this is dealing with
the Commandment or the law for
priesthood to officiate in priesthood
and so we know from uh numbers 25 5
10-13 that the Lord chose Levi to be the
priesthood for Israel and Malachi
mentions actually chapter 2 mentions
there that he was uh that again Levi is
the command he he he committed them for
priesthood but Paul is arguing here that
because the Le you know levitical
priesthood was corrupted was not fit was
had was not the right priesthood or had
they had failed in the priesthood the
Lord just I mean would use
another uh seed if you will or another
Royal line for priesthood that was not
going to be the Le levitical priesthood
but the you know in this case according
to like meel like melkisedek he will
arise from the tribe of Judah which is
Jesus from the tribe of Judah so he's
just basically making the argument that
the law the Commandment for the
levitical priesthood
was in need of a change so that Christ
would fulfill the role of priesthood
yeah uh the bottom line is that Jesus
gets uh his functions yes from the
levitical
priesthood but he gets his right to the
priesthood from the order of
melkisedek um basically the law that is
being spoken of here is that the
levitical
law required pre to be from the tribe of
Levi they had to be from the tribe of
Levi but the problem is that Jesus did
not have right a right to the priesthood
through Levi because he was a different
tribe yeah he was of the tribe of Judah
so how could Jesus be a priest if he
wasn't a levite right the answer is that
Jesus was a priest according to a
different law yeah the law of the order
of
melkisedek and and of course melchisedek
you know in the earlier verses of
chapter 7 says that um without father
without mother without beginning or
ending of days that doesn't mean that
melkisedek uh was was eternal yeah it
simply means that we don't have any
record yeah of a genealogy like was
required with the levitical priesthood
yeah and so and so the law of the
priesthood needs to be changed in the
case of Christ so that being from the
tribe of a Judah he could still be a
priest according to the order of
melkisedek correct so so the issue here
is the levitical requirement that the
priest be from Levi yeah Jesus wasn't
because he was from Judah and so the law
of the priesthood had the change to
allow Jesus to be a priest according to
the order of melkisedek Amen pastor and
you know in Malachi to sort of give a
little of biblical evidence of why the
Lord had to do the change or why he had
to get rid of the levitical priesthood
or allow Jesus to be from another
priesthood is because in Malachi chapter
2 and I'll read these verses briefly uh
from five all the way through nine it
says there my Covenant was with him
speaking of Levi one of life and peace
and I gave I gave them to him that he
might fear me so he fear me and was
reverent before my name the law of Truth
was in his mouth and Injustice was not
found in his lips he walked with me in
peace and equity and turned many away
from iniquity for the lips of a priest
should keep knowledge and people should
seek the law from his mouth for he is
the messenger of the Lord of hosts but
notice what it says but you have
departed from the way you have caused
many to stumble at the law you have
corrupted the Covenant of Levi says the
Lord of hosts therefore I also have made
you contemp able and base before all the
people because you have not kept my ways
but you have shown partiality in the law
so here the Lord is sort of giving the
reasons why this the Covenant he had
made with Levi would not be Eternal
because they broke that Covenant their
priesthood became corrupted and so
Christ had to receive priesthood from
the order that is like the order of MKC
from God himself so this is why the this
verse sort of helps understand that the
problem was in the priesthood of Levi it
became corrupted and you know when it
says here that the levitical system made
nothing perfect it's not talking about
moral perfection it's not talking
whether a person is sinless or not yeah
what it's saying is that the levitical
priesthood could not actually remove sin
right because chapter 10 says that the
blood of bulls and goats cannot re
remove sin yeah the levitical priesthood
existed
only as a symbol yeah of the priesthood
of Christ in the future yeah uh it it
was not an end in itself it was a
vehicle to teach yeah what Christ would
do and that's why I said that that Jesus
gets the description of his functions as
a priest from the levitical priesthood
but he gets his right to the priesthood
because because he was of the tribe of
Judah he doesn't get his right to the
priesthood through Levi because he
wasn't of the tribe of Levi right he
receives it through the lineage of um
melchisedec right uh and you know if I
could read just Hebrews chapter 10 yes
uh in verse four uh actually verses 1
through 4 it says for the law having a
shadow of the good things to come it's
talking about talking about the
ceremonial and not the very image of
those things which is their reality in
Christ can never with the the same
sacrifices which they offer continually
year by year make those who approach
perfect in other words their sins cannot
be legally forgiven yeah because the
because the blood of bulls and goats
can't take away sin let's continue
reading for then would they not have
ceased to be offered yeah uh for the
worshippers once purified would have had
no more consciousness of sins but in
those sacrifices there is a reminder of
sins every year other words they
couldn't remove sin that's why you had
to sacrifice and sacrifice and sacrifice
and sacrifice but Christ by one
sacrifice took care of it verse four
then says for it is not possible that
the blood of bulls and goats could take
away sins yeah so in that sense Sinners
were not legally saved
correct or made perfect not morally yeah
but their sins legally forgiven until
Christ came and shed his blood once and
for all because that which was repeated
and repeated and repeated in the Old
Testament pointed forward to the once
for all sacrifice of Christ amen amen so
I hope that this helps uh our friend
Joshua to be able to uh to understand
better this this passage we look forward
to have another question from him in the
near future the next question pastor we
have comes to us uh from cat more and
the question is in regards to Noah it
says there I was wondering where in the
Bible does it say Noah warned the anti
the luans of the flood obviously he
built the ark but I can find where it
says he preached to the people about the
coming flood and I can tell um uh cat
that the answer to this question is
found in the book of Hebrews 11 verse 7
because of in Genesis we hear about him
building the ark but notice what Hebrews
11:7 tells us it says by faith Noah
being divinely warn of things not yet
seen moved with Godly fear prepare an
ark for the saving of his household by
which he condemned the world and became
heir of the righteousness which is
according to Faith so this verse is
telling us that as he was building the
ark he he was condemning the world so
even though it's telling us uh you know
it's basically portraying the idea that
while he's building this the arc every
Hammer he's making every cut he's
putting every wood he's doing it's a
ceremony itself is is letting people
know and the spirit prophecy gives us a
much broader understanding obviously but
the Bible does give us the evidence that
he was condemning the world he was
letting people know for 120 years that
that he
was knowing there going to flood
destruction was going to come and so
because of his faithful Act of doing the
will of God in making this Arc he was
being he was a living example a living
sermon in a way of the of the you know
the damage was going to come in the near
future of the flood every Hammer blow
yeah was a sermon exactly because
because it never had never rised never
rained and so here's Noah building a
transatlantic ship hug ship yeah on dry
land where that it had never rained
every Hammer blow was an evidence that
that uh Noah believed what he what he
was doing now the Bible also explicitly
says that he preached in second Peter
chapter 2 and verse 5 it says um let's
read verse five it says and did not
spare the ancient world but save Noah
one of eight people a preacher of
righteousness MH bringing in the flood
on the world of the ungodly exactly so
clearly it says that he was a preacher
of righteousness so here you go Pat
Hebrews Peter tells us about the way
that he preached hope answer and of
course what you brought out from Hebrews
11:7 is very important because it shows
that Noah
believed what he preached exactly
because he could say you know God's
sending a flood and people say what are
we going to do well God will provide no
he actually builds the ship on dry land
and that was a sermon that was more
powerful sermon than what he preached
with his voice exactly exactly well uh
let's continue we have probably for one
more question this comes to us from Dawn
and the question is this why did Jesus
preach to the Samaritans when he himself
ordered his disciples not to go to the
Gentiles or the Samaritans but to the
lost sheep of Israel for the remaining
three and a half years of the 70-year
prophecy if the Samaritans are not
considered Jews or Gentiles then what
are they please explain so this is an
interesting question in regards to the
Samaritans and the apparent um direction
of Jesus not to send them to the
Samaritans but to the lordship of Israel
what can we say about this pastor in
regards to this
question well uh you know I believe that
Jesus uh went in very chosen cases to
the Gentiles not only to the Samaritan
woman right and of course the Samaritan
Villages through the woman but also the
Canaanite woman MH you know who had a
sick daughter and she says please Lord
you know she she's after Jesus and and
it's interesting that several times
Jesus says I haven't found this kind of
faith in Israel yeah uh I Think Jesus
was giving a foretaste of the fact that
the that the U gospel was going to go to
the Gentiles Jesus came
primarily during this last week it says
70y year prophecy it's actually the 70
we prophecy which is 490 years Jesus
came the last week
and that week belonged to the Jews M 70
weeks are for your people and for your
city that was the primary task of Jesus
was to fulfill the final events of the
70 we
prophecies um but that doesn't mean that
he couldn't uh given an
inkling that the gospel was going to go
to the Gentiles in fact when he gave the
U the parable of the vineyard yeah you
know where he sends out Messengers and
they don't pay attention to them they
kill some of them then more Messengers
by the way this is uh from from The
Exodus till the Babylonian captivity the
second group of Messengers from the
Babylonian captivity uh to the coming of
Christ and then in the parable said well
At Last he sends his son yeah they're
going to respect my son but they said
let's take him kill him cast him out of
the vineyard and then Jesus says what do
you suppose that should be done to those
individuals who did that yeah of course
and and they said oh oh they need to be
destroyed miserably they didn't know
that he was talking about them and then
Jesus says the kingdom will be taken
from you and given to a nation the word
ethne which is referring to the Gentiles
will give to a nation that produces the
fruits thereof so even Jesus predicted
that the gospel was going to go to the
Gentiles course so why couldn't he uh as
an exceptional case uh minister to the
Gentiles like he did to the Centurion
for example well that's interesting
pastor and you know in the in the
interview that he had with the woman at
the well with the Samaritan woman he
actually pointed out something that is
is to me very important it says there in
verse 21 when she starts to deflect the
the situation or or the question because
he told her about her experience and her
life and her past and having a husband
or you know having five husbands and not
being married to one right now the woman
you know said to him verse vers 19 she
says I perceive that you're a prophet
our fathers worship on this mountain and
the you Jews say that in Jerusalem is
the place where one ought to worship
Jesus said to her verse 21 woman believe
me the hour is coming when you will
Nether on this mountain nor in Jerusalem
worship the father you worship what you
do not know we know but we worship for
salvation is of the Jews but the hour is
coming and now is when the true
worshippers will worship the father in
spirit and Truth for the father is
seeking such to worship him God spirit
and those who worship Him must Worship
in spirit and truth so Christ actually
sort of tells us there tells her you
know
specifically the you are you don't know
what your worshipping you have a
confusion in your worship experience you
you you're not really following the
truth the Salvation is from the Jews the
lord gave the Jews the truth they are
the chosen people they were the ones
that were given the responsibility to
the light um but then he says the hour
comes when you know such a thing will
not longer exist but that is as you
mentioned was the Lord announcing that
the time for the Jews still was you know
exclusively or or chosen for them until
the 70 week period will end and Jesus is
pointing out that the Samaritans were of
those individuals who had a false
understanding of of the Bible of the
Gospel a false understanding of the um
of the yeah the of of the of the power
of God or the gospel of God so I would
say that the Samaritans are are like
Christians today who do not really
believe in the Bible or do not really
understand the Bible fully uh they
worship tradition they worship many
things that are wrong some of them are
you know follow idolatry you know you
know they follow images and that kind of
thing nothing in the Bible and yet they
themselves call themselves Christians so
the Samaritans were kind of these
individuals that were no real they were
not following truly the word of God even
though they claimed to be followers of
God in heaven so and you know uh the
Samaritans the origin of the Samaritans
is that after uh during the Babylonian
captivity they remained in the land
right and they got kind of contaminated
with uh with false teachings and false
practices of the pagans and so they were
they were Jewish but at the same time
they they became mingled with the other
nations and um I don't know whether I
should use this expression they were
considered half breeds yeah because they
were you know they they they were
corrupted Jews according to according to
the the legalistic Jews correct correct
well I pray that this has answered the
question to our friend on and we thank
you once again for allowing us to um
come to you with this program we pray
that you will continue to be blessed and
don't forget to please keep us in your
prayers and thank you again for your
support that help us to continue to
produce these programs may God bless you
and looking forward to seeing you next
next time here in i' like to know
[Music]